le recyclage servier souvent les gens
qui disent ça nous donne rien de
recycler c'est pas recycler le verre par
exemple est ce que est ce que c'est un
mythe
et qui dit monsieur la boîte donc ici en
fait il ya actuellement dans les
dernières années on établissait les
produits qu'ils étaient exclus du moins
ce qu'on mettait dans le bac bleu il y
en a 15 % qui se rediriger qui était pas
récupérable véritablement écrit sur eux
qui étaient redirigées vers les sites
d'enfouissement sanitaire les derniers
chiffres qu'on a c'est 13% donc une
amélioration à ce niveau là et moi je
pense que à mesure qu'on avance dans le
temps à mesure que les technologies se
développent et j'ai donné l'exemple de
victoriaville
tout à l'heure la performance devrait
éventuellement s'améliorer quoique
encore sur le plan du recyclage on a
atteint un certain plateau et il
faudrait que des produits qui sont pas
considérés comme recyclables puisse
devenir cyclable je vous donne un
exemple vous vous jetez des feuilles de
papier dans votre bac bleu ça fonctionne
bouge tes un livre dans le bac bleu ça
c'est pas considéré comme recyclades et
pourtant c'est du papier mais il ya un
couvert et tout ça donc ça fait pas
partie du spectre des matières qui
devrait lorsqu'il ya là dans le contexte
il faut que les producteurs que
et court entreprises par exemple qui
gère la production des deux s'est
produit est recyclable à éventuellement
qui gère une partie de ce qui est
récupéré des industries qui produisent
les producteurs dont il faudrait que le
spectre des plastiques par exemple soit
soit élargi on ramasse les produits du
numéro en numéro 2 possiblement que le
numéro toile d'une requête est pas si
claires et sabin est ce qu'on peut
demander aux citoyens à l'intérieur de
commencer à analyser et à regarder ce
qui est inscrit sur la barquette les
bans elle est recyclable celle là l'est
pas faut élargir ce spectre et là ce qui
nous permettra éventuellement de d'un os
et le pourcentage de matières
recyclables qui est récupéré des dés la
gestion des matières résiduelles et là
en fait d'arriver à une meilleure
performance mais là il faut développer
des technologies il faut faire en sorte
que les crises et besoin pour ses
produits leur part les remettre sur le
marché donc façon le vert et quand je
vous ai parlé tout à l'heure de l'examen
de victoriaville il ya en plus des
plastiques danse et b il ya du vert donc
il ya maintenant une façon de récupérer
le verre et de le traiter de le remettre
sur le circuit sans que ce soit des
bouteilles télé sans entraîner son
organisation fait aussi de digestion du
verre qui lui permet de faire des sous
produits à ceux du moulin on avance
lentement mais sûrement mais là la
solution à ce qui est demandé et ce qui
est relié à la question faut élargir ce
spectre de produits qu'on doit risques
éventuels
et peut-être éduquer davantage les
femmes je dirais à cette dame là qu'il
faut pas arrêter les bonnes habitudes
qu'on a pris en ce moment la recherche
est penche sur ces questions-là de
valorisation de ces produits là qu'ils
ont bon il y en a le vert c'est un coq
bien spécifiques
il ya des matériaux composites qui sont
étudiées pour
paver les rues pour concevoir des objets
il faut miser là-dessus faut pas perdre
la bonne habitude